we drove here by the way in New York I
live in L.A I drove to New Orleans I
worked there and then I drove up to
Chicago and I worked there for a while
it was cool town and um we got shot at
that was a bit of a bummer but then
otherwise it was a great place who shot
at you what are you talking about oh my
God I tell you about that whole thing
and we were on the shooting um we were
there doing the Justified thing and and
we had this crazy shootout do we not
talk about that no we have not talked at
all we've not talked to tell me what
happened it's a dramatic story I don't
know if you want to hear it's a
long-winded dramatic story I could tell
it and then you can cut it out of the
podcast later okay we won't but go ahead
you wanna try okay so here we
because justified's coming back which
I'm very excited about yep Justified
City Prime Evil and where were you
shooting it
we shot in um Chicago mostly Chicago for
Detroit it takes place in Detroit
um railing goes to Detroit
I play Rayland Givens and then
um we're doing and then I'm also going
to play his brother uh Dave Gibbons and
then his other brother Jim Gibbons
they're triplets
I really wanted to mix it up this time I
was like let's do it why do you ruin
everything we're gonna bring it back I
was like I was like they said
I said what why do I want to bring back
this character I've already played this
character for six years and then I it
hit me I was like what if he had a
brother and then I was like they're
twins and then I'm like wait everyone's
done it Jeremy Irons is down in the
cages on it Lindsay Lohan Van Damme
they've all done twins all the greats
have done it you're right I've done it
and that's when it hit me it was like
the clouds parted I said
triplet
raelyn's a triplet uh and this has never
been revealed in all the years you did
Justified and I've watched them all you
never reveal just start the podcast here
okay because now people are in now
they're in so this is great raylen is
triplets one is Dave one is RaeLynn and
then the other one Jim Gibbons Jim
Gibbons wow the writers their parents
were like we'll call you RaeLynn you
Dave and you Jim the great thing about
my position with the Justified thing is
I can get in the writer's room and
really you know take it up a level they
love me in there so so we're shooting
um we're shooting at night in Chicago in
uh
at this park very very bad neighborhood
it was like one two in the morning or
something and we're about to do a scene
where I'm gonna get in this car we've
got the road closed uh and we're about
to get in this car and we hear gunshots
and we'd heard we'd shot in some pretty
tough neighborhoods so we heard gunshots
prior to this but this was a I don't
know I felt like eight or nine shots
went off you know and we're like that's
across from across the park
and then
um I'm standing next to the director and
he's like that's gunshots you know and
uh and then we hear again
and you know the first ads walking over
and he's like everybody those are
gunshots on the other side of the park
but everybody needs to get down that's
there's the scariest goddamn
thing it went on forever so then we
started hearing cars there's a car like
that
and they're driving you can hear them
driving
and you realize they're coming around
the park headed towards heading right
towards us and there's
and if the gunshots and stuff didn't
already kind of give you a tip on what
kind of people we're dealing with
they completely ignored the road closed
sign you know where it says filming
don't come this way and so they're
coming straight down the street that
we're on right and they're just you know
right this machine gun fire and it was
uh it was just insane did you guys all
you see her all lying down like face
down getting as low as you can it was a
little uh
the first day I remember
you know it's a weird thing because
everybody reacts so differently so
there's everything from people running
and Diving under cars
ever to cruise in those safety vests and
they were all throwing them off and
people are yelling get your safety vests
off because I think at this point we
don't really know who's shooting and why
they're shooting or what they're
shooting at right so it just feels like
you know uh gunfire and cars
um
and there's things that I've been told
happened and things that you remember
happened it was really quite you know
and then there's other people that just
froze you know that you just kind of
need to grab
and and the universal thing I've always
heard about anyone from anyone who has
been around gunfire is that you know
it's gunfire immediately even if you
haven't served in the army or have had
no experience with guns that when you
hear gunfire you know there's no
mistaking it for anything else that's
that was my experience yeah you
uh yeah you kind of knew right away that
there was a
you just know that's not fireworks as
much as you want to know hope that's
fireworks and then the sound of the
engine and the mo it just kept coming
and then
um it was the strangest thing
um next thing I know I I was with a
couple others you know just behind this
car the weirdest thing to be in your
railing wardrobe I know standing behind
this car were you wearing a uh were you
wearing a gun a fake gun yeah yeah see
that's the part of this that's crazy is
you're yeah you're playing rayon Givens
and you're wearing a gun but it's all
for for play acting and then a real
gunfight breaks out yeah and there's
these moments because like when these
things happen everything you know it's
like cliche Everything feels like slow
you know all the beats are very distinct
and I do remember
um
I I don't remember I I was told I
grabbed a PA and and threw her out of
the way
um or I used her as a shield which one
well I my god I've heard it both ways a
wonderful PA Ashley and um the reason I
know her name now is because I was like
well I apparently saved her life so I
should learn her name I don't usually
know the PA's names I think what
happened is I was I grabbed her by the
arm and I said uh babe I ordered a
protein shake like a half hour ago and
then and then I was like oh
someone's shooting at us and then I
threw her down you know what I mean
right like a shield
but I remember crouching down behind the
car and I you can't help it I'm looking
because I want to see you know so I'm
doing that thing where I'm looking
around the corner I'm like this is just
like the show this is so weird I'm like
what are you doing but I'm like I think
it's okay anyway and I saw the first
cargo goes right by us I can hear the
bullets hitting the thing off the back
of the car because the car behind it is
shooting at the car in the front when
things started to become clearer yeah
you know and then the second car goes by
this muscle car
one of those Dodge Chargers all tinted
out and there's a guy shooting a pistol
out the window that's clearly been
modified because it's like right right
and the other guys out the sunroof with
a little machine gun and he's shooting a
machine gun and those guys go by like
100 miles an hour and then and I guess
it I guess at some point you I can't
remember had this moment like well okay
they're shooting at that guy so that's
all right you know they're not shooting
at us and then a third car went by and
the the crazy thing is then they kind of
continued around the neighborhood and
you know you felt like they were coming
back and people were running into it was
just there's no law enforcement coming
in at any point I feel like we're a
little understaffed um yeah that's what
I was gonna say we had you know what's
crazy about that situation we sent three
interns over to arrest them I'm telling
you we had one kid listen I'm telling
Steve Ashley get over there I know right
there's these moments we had a we had
one kid Ben God bless him another PA who
was a friend of my wife's family who was
like looking for a you know summer job
he's a film student he was at the first
corner you know like one of those yeah
you put Pas down there and said oh if
anybody walks down here tell him not to
walk down here because you're shooting
right and turns out he God bless him
when the cars came around he Dove behind
a car his bus stop that he was sitting
in just completely shattered like that
kid would have been dead if he didn't if
he hadn't dove and then a cop
we had a cop at one side we had a copy
of the other you know none uh and that
guy I ran into like a week later
you know and I remember talking to him
like because it went on for a while
longer people
the cars would drove for a little longer
and you just kept hearing gunfire
because people started moving into the
park and stuff this took forever it was
just frightening you know and it's such
a weird thing because you're just
sitting there and there's so much
gunfire
it was like 100 rounds you think
I mean I soon I assume one's gonna hit
me eventually you know you're just kind
of waiting for that moment and it's just
so bizarre and that's when I thought I
should call my agent and tell him to
call my kids and tell them I love them
did you did you you know you go through
an experience like that
did you learn anything from that other
than yeah no it was really I'll tell you
a couple things one I remember talking
that I ran in I was walking down streets
of Chicago and this guy came out and
said hey uh he he goes Tim he goes I'm
he goes I'm I'm I was the cop that was
there that night in the corner and
you invariably with every whether it was
him or whether it was the crew
uh there's this thing where the next
couple days next week or so you're just
did you experience what I experienced
there's a lot of that right what was
what what you know tell me and it's tell
me what you felt like when that happened
in the law enforcement was a was really
helpful because I was like okay
I thought it was crazy did you think he
goes that was a war zone that was crazy
right and um he's like yeah I got home
that night and I realized I had a bullet
hole in my shirt and I was like what are
you talking about he's like yeah my
shirt I realized later a bullet went
through right by his bicep but missed
him completely just went through the
shirt yeah
I mean he had a vest on bulletproof vest
on but yeah he said he said no that's
one of the closer calls I've ever had
yeah he said in those situations he's
like you know they're like us they're
they're just going to take cover you're
not going to return fire these guys are
shooting at each other they got machine
guns he's like if I if I engage in in
any way it's just a mess it just becomes
a bigger mess no you're it was up
it was definitely crazy and then there
was the
you know like that thing where you're
like
uh
you know
people will say oh you seemed real chill
you seemed really cool you kept it all
together and I was like that's funny
because that's not the way I remembered
it you know yeah um yeah
the next day
the next day was more emotional it was
like 24 hours later when you when we
were like saying Okay We're Not Gonna
I we were supposed to I was supposed to
shoot the next night and not again in
another bad part of town and I remember
thinking
I don't want to go to work I was like I
remember like I was like I'm not sure I
want to drive down to you know to the
90s and shoot again and I called the
producers and I said you know I feel
like I should speak up you know because
I don't want to shoot and I'm assuming
the crew doesn't want to shoot
should we be everybody taking a Beat
and that was the more emotional day
when you realized when everyone when
they came back and said yeah I think
you're right I think we need to
shut down that's when all of a sudden
you're like okay now there's like tears
coming down because you realize oh no so
it really was yeah yeah you know I
mean like if we all went back to work
and maybe we could have in a very
unhealthy way suppressed how crazy that
evening was yeah you all had PTSD you
needed to oh my God every time you'd
hear I already don't like those cars but
boy they just really ruined it for me
you don't like the Dodge uh charger
that's a fantastic car wait a minute are
we cutting to a Dodge Charger commercial
no not at all no we're not getting paid
by them but I think the Dodge Charger or
for my money the Challenger are classic
muscle cars
I'll I'll take a late uh take a late 60s
version but I think the new models are
good the no model new models are
incredible so look at your comedy mine
what are you talking just going into a
bit I didn't mean to I was trying to be
emotionally available and then I
remembered who I was
it just fell apart